our biggest concern is the difficulty
that micro and small entrepreneurs have with
accounting matters accounting is
less formal and more practical and clearer
in difficulties and with less costs our
innovation was to create this discussion in
accounting producing accounting
for portuguese accounting accounting works
with  the thinking of a lot of
sensitive data in the business depends on the
trust of
customers we were born using google
any platform and we needed
an ideal tool for
data processing with
google cloud tools the
data security protocol gives us much more
peace of mind  to deliver results
to our clients and keep their
information safe
tools like the bernanke
tectoy allow our team to
focus on providing solutions without
worrying about infrastructure extensions
our services are 90% more economical
than the
traditional accounting service I have grown  in
me  day 300 53% a year and 2014
in less than two years allowed micro
and small entrepreneurs in 30 cities to
save more than 25 million
reais in accounting services
[Music]
i